this problem has been studied and we
studied and restated again for last four
years in each time a study is done the
people doing the study come to
essentially the same conclusion and that
conclusion is that number one the UK
needs to have additional capacity for
edge bevel and number two of it doesn't
build additional capacity additional
runways it's going to lose a lot of
revenue and a lot of job and then number
three of the growth ought to occur at
each row which is where the public wants
to fly and then I think each time the
study gets done the politicians lack the
courage to implement it and eventually
they call for another study so I think
the answer is pretty clear we need to
build a third runway each row and we
need to get or you need to do a little
runway that he's growing in you get out
of it as properly as possible what do
you say to people like the mayor of
london who say actually air travel is so
important now we need to build a new
state-of-the-art airport some cities
hong kong as the example have done that
um they well they do some air but look
the answer is you know you commissioned
a group of people and a group that
people go out and they look and break
the tail at all of the facts and this
has been done several times and the
people who do these studies our
responsible businessman that if people
with well-established in there and I
smart and and are honest in fact as they
reached the same conclusion every time
so the answer into the Mayor of London
is raw and as far as people in the air
industry are concerned in the United
States and abroad I mean how do you
regard dealing with Heathrow compared to
dealing with other international
airports around the world is it more
tricky yes Heathrow has been Heathrow
has been they had a lot of difficulties
Heathrow of courses is the capacity of
Heathrow is a very strain it is fully
you I've everybody's doing everything
possibly get every conceivable
playing on those runways in the
consequences it makes it makes operating
a very difficult but the fact that is
the world's airlines want to take their
customers where they want to go so and a
great many people want to go to the UK
and they want to go there my way people
in a consequence is that where the a
longhorn a fly not because yell at the
time being tractable but because that's
where customers want to go but an
airline like American wouldn't think
about shifting its business to Schiphol
or France or I don't know in some cases
even Dubai would it well of course not
it but the fact but the fact of the
matter is capacity they did the world
the world's customers there are more
customers who want to fly the more
places all the time if if the Air Lines
cannot take them to each row some of
those passengers will be elect to go to
other places and the consequences and
they'll go by different routes if you
can't go to a place where you want to go
by way of Heathrow up by where the UK
and then maybe you'll go by way of
Munich or maybe you go by way of
Amsterdam well maybe you go by webcast
and of course that will divert wealth
and jobs away from the UK I think that's
not in the UK's interest and the
consequences I I hope people see you
know the United States and the UK and
this very long-standing linkage and
relationship we've got a lot of friends
in the UK I I hope the government will
make the right choice and build another
runway to eat well and what is wrong
with Gatwick nothing wrong again except
their customer don't go there they want
to go to eat well it's crandall thank
you very much indeed yeah